the following is intended for those over
the age of 20 or those old enough to
have shoeboxes full of photos that came
from film for those who don't know what
film is it was sort of like snapchat but
not really my grandma was beautiful
my mom was young I was naked these
photos are so great but if I don't
rescue them soon they'll just fade away
it's time to digitize it's crazy how
many of our most important memories live
only in an album or box where they can
easily be lost or damaged even crazier
how much easier it is nowadays to fix
that new smartphone apps and really fast
scanners take our old photos into the
future option one is the cheapest but
also the most tedious all you need is a
smartphone and an app Google's new free
photo scan app for iOS and Android is
one of the simplest to use clean off a
well-lit surface place down the photo
and point the camera at it the app
prompts you to capture different angles
of the photo so we can remove glare crop
out the surface background and improve
the quality the big downside
you can't enter the date the photo was
taken photo mine for ios and android is
similar but does let you once you input
the date the photo was taken photo
managers and other apps won't think 1975
photo was taken in 2016 but good luck
snapping hundreds of photos one at a
time which brings me to option two
Epsons $550 photo fast scanner
it's way speedier and way more expensive
plug the printer into your Windows PC or
Mac put a stack of photos in the feeder
and it's ready to scan one photo a
second before you start the software
asks you what year or date the batch was
taken and if you won epson software will
automatically save a copy of the photo
that's been enhanced and color corrected
it looks pretty good though apparently
it doesn't have an anti awkward
correction
the biggest problem is that the scanner
can get jammed can somebody help Aunt
Laura stuck in the scanner again the
last option is to completely outsource
the job to a male in photo scanning
service like scan my photos get your
photos together organize them with some
post-its then put them in the scan my
photos prepaid box and send them in the
mail the company will scan them and send
you the digital copies on a DVD of
course you will need to find a DVD
player ah yes
pay an extra twenty dollars and they'll
upload them for you to download the
prepaid box service starts at one
hundred and forty five dollars and
includes scans for as many photos as you
can fit in the box around eighteen
hundred that's about eight cents of scan
I like the Epson option the best of
course five hundred fifty dollars is a
lot to pay but you could split the cost
with other family members I mean can you
really put a price on memories okay
maybe some shots don't need to live on
forever